[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mercredi 8
avril 2020 23e jour de confinement dans
ce contexte de crise sanitaire nouvelle
édition spéciale sur tv 78
depuis le début de la pandémie le coc
vie de 10 9 a causé la mort de 209
personnes dans les hôpitaux du
département
d'après les derniers chiffres de santé
publique france du 7 avril 2020 992
personnes atteintes du virus sont
hospitalisés sur le territoire dont 189
placé en soins intensifs
enfin pour être complet sur le bilan
sanitaire cinq cent cinquante et une
personnes yvelinoise ont pu retourner à
leur domicile de suite à l'amélioration
de leur état de santé
conséquence de cette crise sanitaire
l'activité économique plonge d'après la
première estimation de la banque de
france la croissance a baissé de 6%
durant le premier trimestre une
évolution jamais enregistré depuis la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
dans ce contexte au 6 avril 2020 plus de
onze mille entreprises ont demandé un
recours au chômage partiel dans le
département des yvelines
écoutez à ce propos jean noël barrot le
député de la 2e circonscription des
yvelines dans les grandes entreprises du
secteur de vélizy du secteur de
saint-quentin les entreprises ce sont
les grandes entreprises les grands
groupes se sont organisés pour
poursuivre leur leur production en
télétravail notamment quitte pour
certaines à arrêter leur production
c'est le cas d'airbus qui s'est arrêtée
une grosse semaine de manière à
réorganiser ses systèmes et ses jeux ses
chaînes de production afin de respecter
les consignes sanitaires
en revanche pour toutes les petites
entreprises du commerce et de la vie
d'avant des difficultés très grande et
donc on est à leurs côtés pour pour
essayer de les accompagner dans la
mobilisation des dispositifs mis en
place par l'état et par les banques de
manière à ce qu'elles puissent être
préservés des difficultés qu'on est en
train de traverser
à paris le préfet des yvelines a décidé
de renforcer les règles de confinement
en interdisant la pratique d'une
activité physique individuel entre 10h
et 19h une interdiction qui a pris effet
aujourd'hui et qui pour l'instant est
maintenue jusqu'au 15 avril
une décision motivée notamment par un
regain d'affluence le week-end dernier
dans notre département
le château de versailles n'est pas le
seul monument à avoir fermé ses portes
c'est le cas aussi de celui de breteuil
située à choiseul une situation
difficile alors que l'an dernier le site
battait son record historique de
fréquentation avec plus de 125 mille
visiteurs c'est également la première
fois depuis 1969 que son propriétaire le
marquis henri-françois de breteil
redécouvre le site totalement vide pour
la période de pâques
lucas plessis ouvrir les jardins pour
les chasses aux oeufs des enfants
écouter le dow a perdu provisoirement la
vie qu'on lui avait donné depuis 50 ans
l'impression qu'on est sous louis xiv ou
moi je vais jalava ce que je vais tout
le temps ici mais mes enfants etc sont
arrivés la nuit
si villa fermeture nous avons trois
personnes qui continuent à travailler
ici sur les dix qui sont plutôt des
personnes qui sont des entretiens et des
travaux et parce que ça il y en a
toujours
en revanche les personnes qui étaient là
pour l'animation pour le guidage des
visites et cetera sont en chômage
partiel puisqu'il n'y a plus de travail
pour eux
malheureusement et notre effort on
puisse rev'it rouvrir les portes du
château du patrimoine à l'activité
culturelle et notamment le monde du
spectacle vivant
humoriste danseurs compagnie de théâtre
ne sont pas épargnés par la crise
sanitaire
dans ce contexte l'ensemble des salles
de divertissement ont fermé leurs portes
alors comment les établissements et des
artistes font face dans les yvelines les
éléments de réponse avec aurélie rond
les salles de spectacle ont été parmi
les premiers lieux à fermer leurs portes
en raison de la crise sanitaire des
mesures qui ont eu comme conséquence un
coup d'arrêt brutal de la saison en
cours
à montigny le bretonneux le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines estime la
perte financière sur les recettes de sa
billetterie à 150000 euros
pour l'instant on essaie de ne procéder
pas à pas l'or par exemple là je
travaillais ce matin avant que que vous
mmes à pied sur la possibilité de
décaler certains des spectacles à la fin
juin mais on travaille quasiment que sur
des hypothèses c'est ça qui est très
compliquée en fait avec cette période
c'est qu'on travaille avec des
hypothèses diverses
là par exemple hypothèse c'est de se
dire que le théâtre pourrait rouvrir au
public vers la semaine du 22 juin où la
semaine du 29 juin où quelqu'un on
essaie de décaler certains spectacles
prévus en mai au mois de juin
parmi les personnes directement impacté
les artistes attrape la troupe de déclic
théâtre compte sept salariés permanents
et une trentaine d'intermittents du
spectacle tout au long de l'année
il venait tout juste de présenter leur
dernier spectacle au public
écran noir quand la crise sanitaire a
débuté
l'arrêt net des activités a soulevée dès
le départ pour nous la question des
salaires des intermittents du spectacle
qui sont trouvés près de de travail du
jour au lendemain
privés de salaire et privés d'heure
puisque puisque le calcul des heures est
très important pour le statut et les
renouvellements despatie des
intermittents du spectacle est-ce que
malgré tout vous gardez vous dire les
sourires j'imagine
on va garder effectivement le le sourire
démarche positive la crise sanitaire qui
est d'ailleurs source d'inspiration pour
de nombreux artistes confiné dans son
appartement à vélizy l'imitateur stan
bennett partagent chaque jour sur les
réseaux sociaux une vidéo
comment
[Musique]
l'humour choisit également parle
yvelinoise laurie père et faute de
pouvoir être sur la scène du théâtre
république à paris elles partagent
régulièrement ses conseils confinement
et sa vision de la situation
je passe vous rappeler à quelques temps
on était quand même en train de se faire
livrer de la neige dans les pyrénées et
la hyundai la febba voilà la goutte de
trop la bavure
il a bouffé un point gaulle 1 et on en
est là coronavirus besoin comme la
course où nous arrange audio les saumons
d'élevage sont souvent bio l'estomac des
vaches medina le lot ou h qui a des news
nicolas hulot avec le confinement les
cinémas ont été dans l'obligation de
fermer leurs portes nous n'irons donc
pas dans les salles yvelinoise mais
rassurez vous à la place nous vous
proposons des films à regarder
directement depuis votre canapé de la
sélection du jour est faite par bertrand
pigné spécialiste cinéma dans les
yvelines
dans mon canapé puisque c'est l'occasion
de s'installer et de prendre le temps de
regarder de fouilles et de chercher de
s'intéresser de se cultiver et et bien
je vous propose une plateforme qui
s'appelle imago tv en un seul mot même
âge et aux tv.fr et alors c'est une
plateforme très engagé c'est une
plateforme gratuite sur les questions de
la transition écologique la transition
économique et voilà du monde dans lequel
on vit puis du monde dans lequel vers
lequel on se dirige puisque la crise
climatique est aujourd'hui quelque chose
que tout le monde a bien en tête
c'est une sélection de plus de 2500
vidéos podcasts émissions de télévision
morceau démissions etc et aussi de
documentaire de cinéma qui sont mis en
accès libre et qui sont catégorisées par
thème alors il ya des thèmes surface il
ya évidemment donc dans les
documentaires et des thèmes sur l'éveil
des consciences les alternatives sur
l'écologie la santé l'alimentation quand
on voit toutes ces choses là alors vous
y retrouverez des films qui sont sortis
en salle 1 vous y retrouverez par
exemple en quête d'autonomie
[Musique]
quel autre film était déjà sorti en
salles en quête de sens par exemple un
des films comme ça
human le film de yann arthus-bertrand
des films qui sont qui posent des
questions sur notre monde et qui
permettent d'y réfléchir
et puis tout ça évidemment accompagné de
liens vers des sites et des des contenus
qui permettent de réfléchir à toutes ces
choses là et ne pas rester complètement
tout seul sur son canapé
confiné mais de penser le monde pendant
qu'on est confiné
il ya de moins en moins de trafic sur
l'autoroute mais certaines aires de
repos maintiennent quand même leur
activité c'est essentiel notamment pour
les transports routiers de poids lourds
nous nous sommes rendus en début de
soirée sur l'air de repos de limours
briis-sous-forges sur l'a10 les images
de patrick jacques de dixmude
il est 19h l'air de repos de limours
briis-sous-forges sur l'autoroute a10 se
remplit de camions en première ligne
dans la crise sanitaire les chauffeurs
de poids lourds assure la majorité de
l'activité des structures autoroutières
dans ce contexte vinci a noué un
partenariat avec ce traiteur yvelinois
chaque soir il sert en moyenne 30 à 35
repas gratuits aux routiers soir c'est
la blanquette avec du riz a pas une
petite mousse au chocolat ils ont à
coeur de baguettes de pain une bouteille
d'eau et puis voilà face emporté il ya
découvert il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour
manger dans le camion on est présent
mais pour aider les routiers finalement
à faire une pause agréable donc leur
offrir un repas chaud et puis et puis
aussi et surtout leur permettre de
recharger leurs flacons de gel
hydroalcoolique
ils sont actuellement en première ligne
pour à huit tailles et tout un chacun
les employés du transport routier sont
soulagés de bénéficier de ce type de
service parfois ils se retrouvent dans
des situations compliquées
merci manger grand problème wafa
monstres et à suisse
problème tous problèmes des problèmes
yahya yahya à la hauteur où ce problème
ces conditions de route aux gens sont
assez idéal serait que mad monkey roulin
ça faut pas se voiler la face
mais aujourd'hui
et les stations le soir en live c'est
fermé sur cette aire de repos la station
service reste ouverte 24 heures sur 24
les employés sont équipés pour assurer
leur mission offre alimentaire de
boissons chaudes et de carburant tous
les services habituels sont maintenues
avec quelques adaptations
généralement on est 3 4 le matin trois
quatre l'après midi on est passé à deux
personnes le matin de personnes l'après
midi et deux personnes la nuit en fête
pour avec un équilibre entre du
personnel d'entretien et le service en
fait
haute de vente en fait en caisse pour
une continuité d'activité en fait un
d'aujourd'hui on travaille
essentiellement avec tous les chauffeurs
routiers tous les services d'urgence en
fait qu'ils peuvent passer par rapport
au carburant donc oui on est sur une
tendance entre mois 3 - 60 et -80% quand
même sur le sur le site quoi d'après les
estimations du groupe vinci autoroutes
le trafic autoroutier aurait diminué de
16% entre le 1er et le 20 mars 2020 une
conséquence assez insolite depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire la
consommation de farines chez les
particuliers a quasiment triplé un
surplus d'activité pour les fabricants à
l'image des moulins de versailles
cette entreprise familiale existe depuis
1905 transforme du blé local en farine
et s'adresse aussi bien aux
professionnels qu'aux particuliers
elle a fermé sa boutique versaillaise
mais s'est concentrée sur la vente en
ligne
les propos recueillis par aurélie 11 ont
fait face en ce moment un afflux massif
des commandes sur internet à savoir que
en une heure il ya deux ou trois tonnes
de farine qui sont évacuées chaque jour
sur internet en une heure c'est à dire
pas mal je remets le stock ou les jours
vers 19 heures en moins d'une heure qui
part on produit plus de 1 kg de 5 kg on
sait très prono fage ça prend plus de
temps à fabriquer du coup ça nous
obligerait aussi à embaucher un terme
tout en prenant des précautions faut pas
s'inquiéter nous tend content tu ne peu
de personnel dans l'entreprise de temps
bonne santé et que et que on a de la
fâcherie on arrivera
à produire de petits culot à rambouillet
depuis le 16 mars la bergerie nationale
n'est plus ouverte au public un site qui
regroupe pôle administratif pôle
formation centre équestre mais aussi
ferme pédagogique boutiques et
exploitations agricoles impossible donc
de stopper toute activité
d'autant que la période en matière de
production laitière est cruciale le
récit de wilfrid richy sur des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude de troupeaux
de brebis soit près de 400 animaux mais
aussi 70 vaches laitières la ferme de la
bergerie nationale à rambouillet se doit
donc de poursuivre son activité malgré
le confinement depuis le 16 mars plus
d'accueil plus d'animations mais un
tiers des effectifs restent en activité
cinq salariés veille au bien être des
bêtes mais aussi à trouver de nouveaux
moyens de valoriser la production et de
poursuivre la vente ce qui a changé
c'est principalement au niveau du
secteur laitier lait recueilli si nous
avons un troupeau de vaches laitières
qui est principalement destiné à la
production de yaourts et de fromage pour
les cantines scolaires
donc évidemment à del annonce de la
fermeture des établissements scolaires
le carnet de commandes a été annulée en
totalité le lait est aujourd'hui
principalement transformé en fromage le
surplus de production est commercialisée
dans des enseignes locales ou par
d'autres exploitants agricoles alors une
solidarité générale qui s'est mise en
place autour du monde agricole
cirque on voit vraiment un regain
d'intérêt de la part de
des commerces pour valoriser les
produits locaux et est donc en quelque
sorte en bénéficient de cet élan là au
niveau du territoire
la boutique sera aussi réouverte
dorénavant le samedi mais uniquement
grâce à un système de drive le bon de
commande est à télécharger et à renvoyer
par mail
les achats seront à récupérer de 10h à
12h ou de 14h à 17h aujourd'hui on est
en train de créer tout un tissu
commercial autour de nous peut être que
ce sera bénéfique à long terme ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup plus de notre
activité touristique
parce que là on sait que l'année 2020
sera enfin définitivement mauvaise au
niveau touristique
donc voilà les inquiétudes se portent
plus sur ce secteur-là un système
temporaire pour limiter au mieux
l'impact sur le site
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci de nous avoir suivis prenez soin
de vous et surtout restez à votre
domicile et on se quitte sur ces images
des humoristes yves binois qui restent
mobilisés à travers ses vidéos postées
sur les réseaux sociaux
excellente soirée à vous sur tv 78
schmid coiffeur mais voilà si bien qu'on
aura besoin de bras écoutez
je l'espère et robes qu'elle a sorti ça
sera le stress pour tenir jusqu'à
mandatrice site a des poils je fais
aussi des biberons jour à savoir leurs
biens rodez moins de 10 ans
[Musique]